hey out there everybody
yes it's just me alone again uh when i'm
recording this
uh tom actually had to go out and do a
supply run today uh because we were
running out of [ __ ] everywhere
and i was like you know we really need
to record today and then he was like
well i really need to go do that so and
you know this movie um he kind of
watched it
partly but um he couldn't really uh hang
with it i guess
so he's like well you can just handle it
because you like this movie and he's
like i didn't really like it because it
was too
uh surreal for him it was just like too
out there
and uh he wasn't really into it so i
decided that i was just gonna talk about
it myself
this is alejandro jodorowski's film
santa sangre from 1989.
now i saw this movie a really long time
ago probably like 15 or 20 years ago
because um i me and my friend use was we
used to hang out at her house like all
the time
and uh have sleepovers and whatnot and
we were always like trying to watch like
the weirdest [ __ ] ever like we really
were into
just very weird cinema so this was one
of the ones that we ended up watching
and i remembered like really really
liking it and some of the images like
really stuck with me for a really long
time
but i hadn't um seen it for
ages and then the other day i was
scrolling through all the [ __ ] on
to be and i noticed that it was on there
for free so if you haven't seen it and
you want to watch it it's
on to be for free right now at least in
the united states so i decided
what the hell you know i will watch it
again because it's been so long since
i've seen it see if i still like it as
much and we'll talk about it on the show
and um it's interesting because i had
forgotten
a lot of stuff about this movie but like
a lot of the images like when i saw the
movie again like really really stuck
with me
i mean the thing about alejandra
jodarowski is i mean anybody that's into
weird cinema or you know surrealist
cinema or anything like that
knows who the dude is i mean i guess he
kind of came to prominence i'd
you know the early 70s i want to say um
with el
topo which was kind of like a weird
funny western kind of i haven't seen
that for a really long time either
and it made like the midnight movie
circuit in new york city was like a huge
like uh midnight movie success like
those big lines and like everybody was
talking about it
um and he also made one called the holy
mountain which
is even weirder than this one if that's
possible
i feel like this movie
it usually gets called a horror movie
which i guess it sort of is
but it's like a surrealist horror movie
it's kind of like
psycho except with
weird giallo elements and also if
everyone involved is on acid but like
interestingly
alejandro jodorowsky has said that he's
like the thing about
making these types of surrealist movies
and stuff it's like yeah you know
everybody says
oh it helps to be on acid to watch it
which i'm sure it probably does
but he wants the movie itself
to give you the same feeling as if you
were on acid
without actually being on acid and
i think to a large extent he does
succeed
now even though this movie is surrealist
it's not super hard to follow you know
what i mean it's like stuff does happen
in it there is like a story behind it
like i said it's almost kind of like a
weird like
mexican uh you know acid trip version of
psycho
in the sense that it's kind of like a
slasher it kind of has
the weird like [ __ ] up dynamic between
the son and the mother
um you know and the mom is like making
him kill women and stuff so it's kind of
like through that same lens
i would say too that it also has a
little bit of a giallo sensibility
because it was co-written by claudio
argento the brother of dario argento
so in the sense that the murders
are very stylized like very
over wrought very um gory like
over-the-top gory
like almost ridiculously so and um so
that's very giallo like and there's also
um a lot of the lighting and so like the
really really bright
like pink lights and blue lights and
just everything is just very
grotesque you know what i mean it's like
a you know that's uh it's just a whole
like grotesque aesthetic to it
so the story of santa sangre
and like i said this came out in 1989.
um
it's actually set in mexico but it's in
english it's all dubbed into english
um much like a lot of the italian movies
of the period where they just dubbed
everybody into one language
this is kind of like that too so it's um
it's weird because it almost i don't
know if he did it on purpose or if it
was just like an expedient
type of you know we just want to release
it in america so we'll just like dub
everything in english
but i think it does help with like the
surrealist atmosphere of it a little bit
because the dubbing is like a little bit
weird and a little bit off
so um so this takes place in mexico
and there's it's kind of centered around
a circus
um basically called the grinko circus or
like circus de granger or something like
that
so it starts out when the main character
whose name
is phoenix when he's a kid now
this kid is played by one of uh
alejandro yodorowski's
sons uh as a kid and also when he's
older in the movie
that is all that is another one of his
sons who was an adult at the time like
in his 20s or whatever
so this little kid is in the circus he's
like the child magician or whatever
and his dad orgo is like this big
like disgusting pig of a man who's just
like always like
rooting around after the women or
whatever and he's the knife thrower
and his mom concha
is um like an aerialist like she hangs
up by her hair
and like does all this stuff like up on
a rib and like trapeze
type stuff now
this is okay this is some messed up [ __ ]
like i said
i'm going to describe this one i'm going
to spoil it so you know if you haven't
seen it yet it's on tubey for free if
you want to go watch it
you know take a couple tabs and like sit
there and watch the [ __ ] and like just
let it
i it's gonna sound like i'm tripping
balls like when i tell everybody what
happens in it if you don't know
but i or that you're tripping balls i
don't know but i assure you neither one
of the stripping balls that well i don't
know about you but i'm not
um but this is like some crazy [ __ ] that
happens in the movie
so um so phoenix is having kind of a
rough day like his dad
is like i said he's kind of an abusive
pig his mom
is kind of uh is kind of wacky i mean
she has she's not only does she work in
the circus
but she is also like the head priestess
or whatever of this cult like a
religious cult
that is called santa sangre or holy
blood
um and it worships their patron saint is
this
girl that got raped and got her
arms cut off so they have this little
ramshackle
um church that they've built
and it has this big pool of ostensibly
blood in the middle and then they have
like a paper mache
kind of icon of this like girl like with
a little school uniform like with no
arms
and uh so they kind of worship her so
when you're introduced to her character
at first
i guess they built this little
ramshackle church like on someone else's
property like some developer or some
developer wants the property or
something it's not like super clear
and so they're going to
tear it down so they end up doing that
so like i said you're
what you're seeing when you're seeing
phoenix as a kid
is you're seeing that all the like
trauma that happened like over a really
brief period that ended that
like explains like what happened to him
later on
so so he sees his mom
like you know trying to keep the church
from getting torn down but they don't
succeed they bulldoze
bulldoze it and she's like freaking out
and everything
so he gets upset about that then he sees
his dad orgo going after
the tattooed lady who's like this you
know real big like voluptuous
uh chick with like all this red curly
hair and she's
uh you know she does this [ __ ] [ __ ]
where she's like sticking her butt in
her face like
back in toward him and everything and i
guess she's like the
uh you know the subject of the night of
orgo's knife throwing so i guess they're
kind of having a
affair or something and she's also the
tattooed lady is also an
[ __ ] because she has a daughter named
alma
who is a mime and like um a tightrope
walker
who's like a little girl and uh her and
phoenix have kind of a thing like
they're kind of
you know in love sort of you know they
don't like go super into it but you can
tell that they're it's like young love
and everything
but um the tattooed lady is like really
mean
to alma and it's like really kind of a
[ __ ] to her
so what ends up happening here is that
orgo
is [ __ ] around with the
with the tattooed lady and
concha the what the mom she finds out
about it
and she's like up there doing her act or
whatever and
she sees the two of them like making out
and then like going off
you know to have sex in the trailer so
she like makes the people like let her
down
and then she runs in there and throws
acid
on her husband's uh crotcheler area
let's put it like that and uh so he
flips the [ __ ] out
and runs out of the [ __ ] like after her
and she runs out and then
he catches up with her and
cuts off her arms like he takes like two
of his
uh knives and like cuts her arms off and
they kind of fall to go it's like a
great shot like they shoot it from above
it's like just it's crazy
and then he cuts his own throat now
after this
because orgo is not there anymore and
this is all turned into a huge [ __ ] show
the tattooed lady takes off with alma
um and this upsets uh
you know phoenix very much because not
only has he has his dad
died in front of him he's seen his mom
uh get her
get his get her arms cut off in front of
him his little girlfriend gets taken
away oh and i forgot to mention too
that also one of the elephants dies and
that's like really traumatic they have
like this hilariously
grotesquely weird like funeral for the
elephant with like this big giant coffin
and they like take it through the
streets and like
then they dump the carcass like down
this thing and like all these people at
you know this kind of shanty town like
come and get like get all the meat out
of the coffin it's like it's crazy
and uh so that was upsetting to him and
also before
his dad died his dad like pretty much
carved like a tattoo of like a phoenix
or like an eagle or something like in
his chest like to make him a man or
something
so this kids had a rough day so so all
of that [ __ ] happened
like i don't think it was a single day
but it's the way they shot it it kind of
just seemed like a day or two
so then they kind of skip forward to
uh when phoenix has grown up and i guess
he's been
in a lunatic asylum for like all this
time
ever since those incidents occurred when
he was a kid
and he basically thinks that i mean true
to his name i guess he thinks he's a
phoenix because
he spends most of his time like in his
cell and he's naked
and he like sits up in a tree and they
br
you know they put a tree in there for
him which was nice i guess um
so he sits up there and like they bring
him food and [ __ ] but he won't eat it
like the only
food that he'll eat if they have to
bring him like a raw fish and then he'll
sit there and like eat the fish like a
bird would
i guess so there's that whole thing
now it comes to pass that so i guess
he's been in here for years
and there's kind of an inciting incident
which i guess i didn't realize was the
inciting incident when i was
actually watching it because i'm just
sitting here going what the [ __ ] does
this have to do with anything but
when i thought about it afterward i was
like oh well that was what uh you know
caused him to
cause the you know the events of this
timeline to like come to fruition
so what ends up happening is that
they're
i guess the the people like the staff at
the hospital
they take the patients like to the
movies every now and then
now it seems like phoenix
is not only the only i guess he's i
don't know if he's the only adult
because the rest of them look like kids
but all the other patients have like
developmental disorders they have like
down syndrome and stuff and they're just
like real like kids with down syndrome
that are in this movie
so so they're gonna take them to see
robinson crusoe i think so they
take all the kids down to the movie
theater but then they leave them in the
care of this super
sketchy like dirt bag and he's like you
know
i have some i have a better idea we
could do something more fun than going
to the movie so he gives
all the down syndrome kids cocaine and
then takes them to
like a whorehouse um they all seem to
enjoy themselves
but so i guess like the next day like
after they have brought them back to
the hospital so i guess like the cocaine
and
the experience of the red light district
and everything and i think while they
were out he also saw like the tattooed
lady because she was
like out there hooking or whatever and
so
this kind of causes him because he says
he feels really good and everything but
then he hears
his mom's voice like calling him from
outside of the asylum
and he looks out there and she's
standing out there like with no arms so
he escapes from the asylum and they go
off together
now what ends up happening here or so
you think
because like i said i'm gonna spoil it
because i had for totally forgotten like
what the ending of this was
so what you think happens is that i mean
she has no arms obviously
so he starts acting as her arms
in like a weird it's not a burlesque
show but it's kind of like a performance
like she comes out and sings and
she does this weird like spoken word
thing about the garden of eden and
everything
and she can and he like stands behind
her and he has his nails all painted
like a woman's nails and everything and
like he's like moving her
hands for her so he's pretty much acting
as her hands
also though he thinks
that she can control the hands
all the time like even when like with
her mind i guess
so it's kind of like the hands of orlac
if you guys saw like that old silent
movie
where the guy loses his hand he was a
pianist and he lost his hands in an
accident and then he got or he
thought that he got like a murderer's
hands and so he thought that he like had
lost control of his body parts and they
were doing [ __ ] like without his
authorization
so that's kind of what's going on here
phoenix thinks that his mom
is controlling his hands and his mom
is making him go around killing
women much like like i said norman bates
and his mom
because i guess in the mom's mind um
they're all [ __ ] so i mean the first
one to go is the paint
is the tattooed lady i mean obviously
because she had a personal beef with her
so that's like a pretty hilarious and
like
grotesque scene like you know it's very
jealous it's just like stabbing and just
blood spraying everywhere
so but as it goes on he starts to
you know he kills all these women but he
doesn't
seem to have any control over it and he
seems to be like getting really upset
about it
um so while all that's going on there's
also like once the tattooed lady gets
killed
alma is still around and um she's grown
up now a little bit obviously
and the mom has been pimping her out
which
you know that's lovely and she's like
trying so
the the mom gets killed she escapes and
then she goes and tries to find
uh phoenix so
the as it goes on like all these women
get murdered
and finally like phoenix is kind of
trying to
get get away from like his mother's
power i guess like he picks up this one
um i guess it's a a trans woman
but it's a uh she's like a real big you
know but i don't know i said i don't
know if it's an actual trans person or
if it's
just a man in drag like you can't really
tell
but he thinks that phoenix thinks that
she's like well
this person will be able to stop me
because they'll just beat the [ __ ] out
of me like before i can kill them and
then everything will be okay
um but it doesn't quite work out the way
he wants it to
and what ends up happening is that
finally alma
finds him and she i guess she's like
alma means soul
i guess so i guess she's supposed to be
like she was like his salvation
so she comes there and she shows him
like the weird thing for a second you
walk into this house because it looks
like they live in this big crazy
like three-story house and it's kind of
nice and there's like a shrine with the
armless lady and all this other stuff
and um but when alma first comes in
there it looks like a total [ __ ]
like it's all
[ __ ] up and you know the the shrine is
there but all the furniture and [ __ ]
that we've seen
like up to this point is not there
anymore so then you're starting to think
hmm what the [ __ ] is going on here
well as it turns out much like in psycho
the mom died back
in the day like the same day that orgo
died the knife thrower like she died
when her arms got cut off as you
probably would because it was [ __ ]
spraying blood everywhere and you would
bleed to death in seconds so she died
back then
and and i guess phoenix because like i
said it was a real rough day when he was
a kid and he
couldn't deal with it so he basically
dissociated
and after the whole cocaine thing and uh
seeing the tattooed lady again and
bringing it all back after he escaped
from the asylum
he started fantasizing that his mom was
still around
and that he was acting as her arms
and that she was controlling him like
from beyond the grave or something like
that
so as it turned out the act that he was
doing with her like where he was being
the hands like he put his hands like
behind
uh you know they've had these special
sleeves and like to put them in there
and like he would
play the piano for her he would like
knit socks he would do all kind of [ __ ]
i mean
the the way that they set that up it was
[ __ ] great they must have like
rehearsed the [ __ ] out of that because
it really did look like
from certain angles it really did look
like her arms
um even though it was him because he was
always like behind her
and you know it's like he's [ __ ]
drinking coffee for her and like eating
and also it was crazy
so you find out that like the act that
he was doing
and all the stuff that he was doing in
the house that we saw before
where the mom was like berating him and
like getting him to play the piano and
like yelling at him who's [ __ ] it up
or whatever
was just a dummy of her it wasn't
really her because she had been dead for
a really long time
so when alma finally
shows him like the dummy and you know
tries to get him to
like come back to himself and realize
that
you know she's dead the whole time and
then it's kind of like this big
triumphant ending even though the cops
come at the end because
he killed a lot of people like as they
show because like you don't realize
because you only see them like kill a
couple of them
but i guess off screen he's killed a
[ __ ] ton because at one point there's a
scene where
all these women like in these veils and
[ __ ] are like climbing at all these
graves that he made like in the yard or
whatever so he's been killing people for
a really long time
so the cops come at the end and they
tell them to put
their hands up like alma puts their
hands up and he
like looks at his arms like they're not
because he thinks they're not his but
then finally he puts his hands up and
he's all excited because he finally
has realized that these are his arms and
he can control himself
and even though now he's probably going
to prison or going back to
the mental hospital because like i said
he's still
he's still a serial killer i mean you
know even though he was crazy and he dis
dissociated but yeah so this movie
like i said it's not as weird as holy
mountain
i can't remember how weird el toppo was
i kind of feel like it was weird but
maybe not as weird as this
this movie is like okay
like tom like i said could not hang with
it because it's just like
he kind of liked at the beginning he's
like i really liked the idea i liked the
kind of the
the look of it but he's like it's just
too
he was like it was just too much it's
just too surreal
he's not a big fan of like surrealist
cinema
which i get that i know some people
aren't it's like i
i see how there's a very fine line
between just being surrealist or being
you know using a lot of symbolism or
stuff and just being pretentious
but the thing about this one is that
i really do this one it has like a lot
of energy it's not just like a weird
it's not just weird for weirdness's sake
is what i'm saying
it's just like a lot of the symbolism in
it a lot of the
you know why it's weird it's weird like
for a reason
he's not just trying to you know be like
ooh does this freak you out ooh does
that freak you out or
anything like that it just seems like he
has a reason for everything that he put
into the movie
not just to be there like weird for the
sake of being weird um
other people might disagree i don't know
but i do feel like
this has gotten like um
you know it's gotten really good like
critical reviews um everything like i
said there's so much symbolism in it
it's essentially a coming coming-of-age
story or a story about
someone coming to terms with grief
coming to terms with trauma like from
their childhood
and learning to stand on their own two
feet and learning to control their own
actions
so it's not like it's just coming out of
nowhere or doesn't have a plot or
anything like that i mean
things happen in the movie you know and
it's this happens because of that and
then that happens because of that it's
like it's
a pretty standard narrative um for a
surrealist film it's just that
a lot of the imagery is very weird and
grotesque
and things like that but i don't know is
it
again this is just kind of like when we
talked about ninth configuration last
week which
uh a couple of you told me that you had
watched because like i said that's a
free
for um free on to be as well and
some people were like man i just i
couldn't get into it which i get
because the first 20 30 minutes of that
or just like
bizarrely off-putting this one i think
is less
off-putting in the sense but you have to
know what you're getting into this is
just like an over-the-top
grotesquery that's kind of like
it's not even i mean david lynch does
surrealism too but this is like a
different
kind of thing it's just it's very very
colorful it's very
circusy it's just very you know
and it's very gory like you know there's
a lot of gore in it a lot of blood
it's not so i don't know if i would call
it a horror movie outright
but it does have like a really lot of
horror elements and it does have a lot
of
giallo elements like i said which should
not be too surprising since it was
co-written by
uh claudio argento um but yeah it's like
check it out it's free
if you want to watch it um just tell me
what you thought of it
or if you've seen any of uh you know any
of jodorowsky's other films
this i mean if you've seen like the
drawings that they did for like his
proposed uh
you know dune adaptation which never
came to pass famously
um you'll kind of know what kind of
visual thing you're getting in for
but yeah check it out tell me what you
think but uh
speaking of giallo this is very
interesting when i was on 2b last night
and i watched
santa sangre and then it has like the
little you know recommendations at the
bottom
one of the recommendations on there was
a documentary
called all the colors of giallo uh about
jello movies uh
obviously so i started watching that
because i was like well [ __ ] man i
would probably wouldn't even have found
that if i because there's so much [ __ ]
on there that you have to like wade
through as i said before
so i started watching i didn't quite
finish it because um you know i was
getting really tired because it was kind
of late and you know it still had like
another half hour to go
i will say that if you are not
real big into giallo movies i wouldn't
recommend it because it's not
a kind of this is an introduction to the
genre you know this is
some of the movies and all this other
kind of stuff it's much more
they just cut they just kind of have a
handful of people like some film
historians they have dario argentos on
there
um dardano sashati who wrote a lot of
lucho folgi's movies
they have like some archival like
interviews with lucio folgi which are
hilarious because like him and dario
argento really did not like each other
so they were like really
[ __ ] so that was very funny um but
yeah
so but so it's just so they have just
like really long interviews
with these people with not and then
they'll have like a few clips
of the movies like in between so it's
kind of like a lot of talking heads but
i mean i thought it was really
interesting but if you're not really
into giallo movies
then i wouldn't recommend it because
it's basically just like really long
interviews with a couple of people
one thing i did really like about it
though was they had
dardana sachet on their talk and like i
said and he
wrote uh he wrote a bunch of lucio
folgi's movies like
including house by the cemetery like his
you know the beyond all those
but he also wrote the psychic uh
otherwise known as murder to the tune of
seven black notes
um which i actually think is my favorite
fulchi giallo movie might be my favorite
fulchi movie
overall although i don't know the beyond
and house by the cemetery are really
good too
but and it's one that and it's i thought
it was interesting because
um dardano sashanti was saying
he's like this is my favorite jello that
i did with lucio folgi and it's like and
i feel like
it sucks because it just it didn't go
anywhere like it didn't get
any good box office like in italy like
people didn't give a [ __ ] about it
nobody really talks about it anymore and
he's like and it's my favorite one it
like came out exactly the way i wanted
it and it was perfect
and it's weird because like even from my
blog like a long time ago
i wrote about that movie and i was like
why the [ __ ] doesn't anybody that talks
about lucio fulche talk about this movie
because i love
that [ __ ] movie it's like a giallo
but it also has a little bit of a
supernatural element too so it's not
like
you know it's not like a real textbook
one but i love
the [ __ ] setup of it because the
setup of it
is this woman who's a psychic obviously
and she has this really weird like
disjointed vision and
the the cool part of the movie it's like
a mystery you know like a jello usually
is but
the cool part of the movie is seeing how
all of this stuff that
she sees in her vision and how she
interprets how it's gonna happen
um but that's not ever exactly how the
[ __ ] ends up happening and also her
vision you don't know
which parts of it are the future which
parts
that are the past and it makes it really
good but it's really really well
constructed
i actually want to do a um retrospective
on it one of these days
uh i used to have it on dvd i don't know
where the [ __ ] it is though it must be
up in the
attic someplace like most of my other
[ __ ] is but yeah so
as i said if you're into like surrealist
horror
um or just not like i said and if you
love like circus kind of [ __ ] because
this is just full of like
crazy circus imagery um then you will
probably love santa sangre if you
haven't seen it
but keep in mind like i said it's very
weird it's very overwrought it's very
gory
um and uh but it's for free
on 2b in the u.s so if you
want to watch it then check it out and
let me know what you thought
in the comments section and i guess
that'll do it for this
lonely movie retrospective
anyway like share subscribe uh you know
do all this [ __ ] that you
normally do and uh i'll talk to you next
time
bye